en el vídeo anterior estábamos
resolviendo el siguiente problema que
dice que si nos tomamos omega una raíz
cúbica compleja de la unidad que no es 1
ok entonces de hecho alcanzamos a ver
quiénes son todas las raíces cúbicas
verdad de una era justamente el 1 y las
otras dos eran menos un medio menos aún
más bien más o menos la raíz de 3 y
entre 2 esas eran las tres raíces
cúbicas y entonces este bueno ya que
descubrimos cuáles eran nos decían que
si les lanzamos un dado justo tres veces
y r1 r2 r3 son los números que se
obtienen en el dado entonces la
probabilidad de que esta expresión sea
cero es decir la suma de omega la r1 más
omega la r2 más omega la r3 sea 0 nos
preguntan cuál es la probabilidad de que
esto pase muy bien entonces lo que
hicimos fue bueno ya que sabíamos que
uno era una raíz podríamos factorizar
este polinomio que esencialmente es el
que queremos resolver y obtuvimos una
expresión cuadrática que pudimos hacer
simplemente haciendo la división
y entonces igual a vamos a hacer o oeste
era 0 oeste era 0 si este azul era 0
entonces obteníamos las otras dos raíces
y una vez que obtuvimos las otras dos
raíces pues entonces nos nos lanzamos a
la tarea de calcular quién era un mega
cuadrado y omega al cuadrado y quién era
omega al cubo entonces con esta
información podemos ya decir muchísimo
del problema porque ya tenemos que omega
digamos omega la 1 es este menos un
medio menos un medio menos la raíz de 3
entre 2 y también sabemos que omega
cuadrado pues es conjugado verdad es
menos un medio más la raíz de 3 entre 2
por iu y también sabemos que omega al
cubo pues es justamente uno y más o
menos platiqué un poco de qué era lo que
pasaba con omega la 4 verdad nos
interesan las potencias que pueden salir
en un dado y eso es 1 2 3 4 5 ó 6
entonces omega la 4
omega al cubo por omega verdad pero mega
el cubo es 1 entonces simplemente nos
queda omega así que omega la 4 es omega
a la 1 ahora bien qué pasa si yo quiero
calcular omega a las 5 omega la 5 es
omega por omega la 4 pero mega la 48
mega entonces nos queda omega por omega
y omega por omega es omega cuadrada así
que este es un mega la 5 y omega a las 6
pues es simplemente como si elevamos al
cuadrado omega al cubo por elevar al
cuadrado mega al cubo es elevado al
cuadrado 1 y esto es omega a las 6
entonces ya tenemos todas las potencias
posibles que pueden salir de un dado en
este en bueno al tirar un dado y ver
cuál cara sale entonces ahora queremos
buscar esta probabilidad déjenme
escribirla
queremos calcular la probabilidad de que
omega a la r1 más omega a la r2 más
omega a la r3 sea 0
esta es la probabilidad que queremos
calcular así que esencialmente lo que
tenemos que buscar son combinaciones de
estos de estas de estas potencias de tal
suerte que nos dé 0 ahora vamos a
observar algo muy fácil si omega sí sí
cierre 1 de r2 y r3 fueran el mismo si
fueran el mismo por ejemplo tendríamos
tres veces cualquiera de estos tres
veces 13 veces este 3 veces este
cualquiera de ellos
entonces si nos damos cuenta tres veces
es a cualquiera de este número nunca nos
va a dar cero así que al menos r1 y r2
por ejemplo tiene bueno al menos dos
tienen que ser distintos ok entonces por
ejemplo si que pasa si éste es si si si
tenemos este y este muy bien que sean
los dos primeros sean estos 2
digamos que tenemos que este es este
primero ok entonces vamos a tener menos
un medio menos la raíz de 3 entre 2 por
iu y digamos que si el segundo es este
es éste
este de aquí este rojo entonces vamos a
tener menos un medio más raíz de 3 entre
2 y muy bien entonces si los sumamos nos
queda estos estos estos dos se cancelan
por ejemplo este éste se cancela con
este y entonces me queda menos un medio
y menos un medio que es menos 1 así que
necesito sumarle para que nos dé 0 pues
necesito sumarle este de aquí entonces
realmente lo que estamos aquí observando
es que como no pueden ser todos iguales
terminan siendo todos distintos cierre 1
sí sí el primero fuera éste y el segundo
fuera el rojo el tercero tiene que ser
el azul sí sí cambian los papeles pueden
pueden observar que pasa exactamente lo
mismo el punto es que no importa como le
hagan necesariamente los exponentes
tienen que ser todos distintos así que
sí tienen que ser todos distintos pues
r1 por ejemplo por ejemplo r uno puede
ser para que nos dé el verde pues tiene
que ser uno o cuatro
r2 tendría que ser para que nos dé el
rojo tendría que ser dos o cinco y r3
para que nos diera uno tendría que ser
tres o seis ahora bien justamente
tenemos la propiedad de que la suma con
nota es decir no importa si si r uno
está aquí o bueno sí sí aquí por ejemplo
tuviéramos omega la r2 más omega la r1
más omega lr3 no importa como como
acomodemos la suma nos da 0 entonces
realmente tenemos que pensar cuántas
veces podemos intercambiar r1 r2 y r3 y
esas son seis veces verdad por ejemplo
empiezan con 14 el siguiente puede ser 3
o 6 y el que le sigue puede ser 2 o 5 y
esencialmente es se puede ver de la
siguiente forma tenemos que acomodar el
exponente en tres casillas
entonces en el primero puede ser r1 r2
r3 tenemos tres posibilidades
una vez que elegimos uno sólo nos quedan
dos posibilidades en la segunda casilla
y en la tercera pues ya nada más nos
queda
así que las el número de combinaciones
es el producto que son 6 o puedes verlo
como las permutaciones que hay de tres
elementos como sea que quieras verlo de
todas formas la probabilidad de obtener
14 a lanzar un dado por son 2 de 6 o lo
que es lo mismo un tercio un tercio cuál
es la probabilidad de obtener r 2 pues
son 2 de 6 que también son un tercio y
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener r 3
también va a ser un tercio entonces la
probabilidad de obtener r1 y r2 y r3 son
multiplicar estos tres que es 1 sobre 27
muy bien ahí ya tenemos la probabilidad
de obtener r1 r2 y r3 pero ahora podemos
intercambiarlo de 6 formas distintas así
que esto simplemente será seis veces la
probabilidad de obtener esta
configuración r1 r2 y r3 en ese orden y
6 por 6 por 1 entre 27 son
entre 27 y que por ejemplo si sacamos
una tercera parte de arriba y abajo nos
quedan 2 entre 9 y ya acabamos con esto
el problema la probabilidad de obtener 0
con estas potencias es dos novenos
verdad simplemente queríamos ver cuántas
combinaciones es el problema se reduce a
ver cuántas combinaciones podemos sacar
de esto y que resulta que hay seis
maneras verdad siempre y eso son sólo
seis porque r1 r2 y r3 tienen que ser
todos distintos todos tienen que ser
distintos así que al final no fue un
problema tan complicado y de hecho creo
que fue un problema muy bonito que
además relacionó el análisis complejo la
los números complejos con la
probabilidad espero te hayas divertido y
que te haya gustado